unser sonnensystem hat jetzt offiziell
einen neuen zweig planeten auf der suche
nach planeten stieß ein astronomie team
der northeastern university und der
university of hawaii auf einen riesigen
brocken mit dem marianischen teleskop
subaru suchen sie den himmel
systematisch nach planet iks ab und sie
vermuten dass da doch draußen noch
zehntausende weitere zwergplaneten vor
sich hin schlummern die vorstellungen
über unser sonnensystem könnten sich
also in der nächsten zeit komplett
wandeln
ja weil es so viel mehr objekte in ihm
gibt und zusätzlich noch planet xx um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinierendes eines videos aber nicht
den kanal nur dann verpasst er nicht
herzlich willkommen 2015 tg 387 so ist
die korrekte bezeichnung des gestürmt im
katalog der internationalen
astronomischen union und dieses gestirn
hat einen durchmesser von 300 kilometern
das forschungsteam gab eben aber auch
einen richtigen namen goblin auf deutsch
in etwa kobold goblin ist ein riesiger
brocken und damit groß genug um als
zwergplanet zu gelten er ist jetzt eine
weitere spur auf der suche nach planeten
denn das erhofft sich das forschungsteam
das anhand von ich sag mal unwuchten in
seiner bahn plane ticks aufgespürt
werden kann
entdeckt wurde er schon 2015 15 aber
jetzt erst offiziell anerkannt und damit
in den katalog der zwergplaneten
aufgenommen er gehört damit in die
gleiche klasse wie pluto und die
entdeckung scheint noch nicht mal
außergewöhnlich zu sein
der beteiligte forscher david trone und
von der university of hawaii
wir denken das ist tausende kleinen
körper wie 2015 tg sein als 780 draußen
an den rändern unseres sonnensystem
geben könnte aber ihre entfernung macht
die entdeckung sehr schwierig umso mehr
aber davon entdeckt würden desto
leichter würde das aufspüren von planet
iks werden aber diese gestirne sind nur
sehr schwierig zu entdecken sie sind
sehr dunkel weil sie sehr weit von der
sonne entfernt sind und tg 387 zieht
eine extrem elliptische bahn um die
sonne an der nächsten stelle ist jetzt
werk planet 65 mal so weit wie die erde
von der sonne entfernt an der weitesten
stelle sind es 2300 mal so viel
wer die erde ein jahr für die umkreisung
der sonne braucht sind es bei goblin
40.000 jahre und ähnliches erwartet man
ja
kompanie nix oder auch planen wir ja
auch genannt wird er soll ja sehr weit
draußen um die sonne kreisen man
vermutet dass es sich dabei wohl um
einen gesteinsplaneten handelt und dass
er wohl den vierfachen durchmesser der
erde hat und maximal zehn mal so groß
ist wie unser heimatplanet er muss sich
nach ansicht vieler forschungsteams wohl
am äußeren rand des sonnensystems
versteckt halten
gemeinsame bahn abweichungen
verschiedene objekte in dieser region
lassen darauf schliessen konkret geht es
um rund 20 größere objekte im
kupfergürtel ein gebiet außerhalb der
neptun bahn weswegen man kann allerdings
bis heute trotz intensiver suche noch
nicht direkt beobachten konnte liegt
wohl an seiner enormen distanz zur sonne
amerikanische wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen vom institute of
technology california hatten berechnet
dass die bahn vom planet iks den
planeten zu dem zeitpunkt seiner
dichtesten erdnähe wohl noch immer 700
mal weiter an der sonne vorbei führt als
die erde mit dem neukunden zwergplaneten
goblin wird die suche jetzt wieder ein
wenig leichter und das forschungsteam
hofft jetzt noch weitere zwergplaneten
zu finden um den bereich in dem planet
iks sich wahrscheinlich befindet weiter
eingrenzen zu können und heute gibt es
übrigens zwei neue videos für euch
unsere video premiere auf dem englischen
krieg zum kanal making plastic vom
plastik waste bioplastics solution for
global pollution dafür hier klicken
ich freue mich auf euch auf dem
englischen kanal stay tuned zu tun